in this episode of cloud performance
Atlas I take a look at some tools to
test Google cloud platforms networking
performance we find the perfect
multitasker stay tuned to find out over
the past few weeks we've been peppered
with all sorts of performance questions
centered around networking and how to
configure GCP to get the best possible
results
now we've got a couple of videos talking
about some developers that we were able
to help but before that I wanted to take
a moment and talk about some of the
tools available to profile GCPs
networking so that you don't have to
write that code yourself first is net
perf which is a commonly used tool for
measuring maximum TCP and UDP bandwidth
performance net perf works by hosting a
server and a client on different
machines and can measure the throughput
between the two ends either
unidirectionally or by directly when you
execute the client it connects to the
server and sends a boatload of data
around now once you install net perf the
server version called net server will be
run automagically so you just need to
pick which instance will be the client
and execute the net perf binary to get
the details on the bandwidth conditions
iperf is a tcp and UDP benchmark it has
several advantages over net perks like a
bandwidth shaping and threaded support
so that multiple streams can be created
getting iperf working is somewhat
straightforward
simply install iperf on each of your
target instances and run the server on
one and the client on the other what we
get is an output from iperf is a timed
stamp report of the amount of data
transferred and the throughput measured
now while iperf and net stats can help
you track latency and throughput the
traceroute tool is useful for measuring
and displaying the route that packets
take across a network it records the
history of the route as well as a
round-trip time of three packets
received from each successive host in
the route if you'd like to see this for
yourself
run trace route on your home machine
here's my result when you can see that
the first hop to the ISP is
significantly slow given our distance
from that service meanwhile check out
the distance between a VM running on
Google compute engine and Google com
much less hops now once you have the
tools it's important to address another
issue how to properly test things this
can be a tricky problem now since
setting up the wrong tests can lead to
inaccurate results which isn't something
you want to be making decisions off of
this is exactly why Google maintains the
perfect KITT bench marker project its
authors have done the due diligence to
set up their testing harness correctly
and reduce the inserted error that might
skew the results so if you're serious
about testing your performance it's
worth playing around with now if you're
interested in a few more details
including some gotchas with the
firewalls to get these tools working on
compute engine
check out the article for this video in
the description below and if you want to
get more great cloud performance content
check out the rest of our videos because
when it comes to performance every
millisecond counts